the left is about to get very harsh with
the right
we've been talking about this mostly in
the realm of social media we don't get
to tweet
whatever you know we don't get to post
certain things on the internet
it's going to be a lot harsher than that
you're going to long for the days when
your biggest problem was what you could
and couldn't tweet
and we've been sounding the warning bell
on this for a long time
it's going to involve the sort of
commerce you're allowed to engage in or
are you allowed to call an uber or are
you allowed to get delivery food
are you allowed to use certain basic
commercial systems are you allowed to to
bank
you know you have a bank right you keep
your money in the bank some
conservatives keep all their money in
their mattress but most i would say
use a bank well that could come into
question
not just for joe schmo on the street
even up to including
the duly elected sitting president
deutsche bank
made an announcement yesterday said that
they will not lend
to trump anymore president trump has
business holdings all around the world
trump obviously takes out loans
to grow his businesses and one of those
banks
that he's worked with in the past will
not lend to him
are they not going to lend to him
because he's not a worthy
creditor or a worthy borrower rather is
that it because they don't think he'll
pay it back no i think he'll probably
pay it back
he's the most famous powerful man in the
world at least on paper
his brand has been extremely successful
for decades and decades
i don't think it's that it's because
they don't like his politics
and so they're not going to lend him
money so he's not going to be permitted
to engage in his commerce to grow his
businesses
now you might say well michael look
that's just the beautiful wonderful free
market working
and don't you love that don't you want a
completely unfettered free market with
no regulations
i don't want that i know that a lot of
liberals
seem to think this is a very powerful
argument against conservatives these
days particularly when we talk about
regulating tech
that's not what conservatives believe
that might be what some caricature
of a libertarian from some cartoon in
the 1980s believes but that's not what
conservatives believe
and it's really not what the
conservative tradition has ever
embraced putting that aside for a second
though
i don't want to live in a society where
people's political views
are going to particularly mainstream
political views
are going to completely ostracize them
from engaging in any kind of commerce
but you say
deutsche bank has no obligation to lend
trump money okay
if trump doesn't have a right to borrow
money i guess none of us do
does trump have a right to use banking
services
does he have the right to put his money
in a bank
do you have that right do you think
banks should be allowed based on
people's political views
mainstream political views to say we're
going to close your bank accounts
put it under the mattress good luck
probably don't have a lot of fdic
insurance on that mattress but
sorry we're not going to do business
with you i don't think so i don't want
to live in that society that is
increasingly the society that we are
going to be living in signature bank
which is a new york lender that has long
catered to the trump family
is closing two personal bank accounts
in which president trump is holding
about 5.3 million
dollars this is according to a spokesman
not for trump
but for the bank the bank is also
calling for the president to step aside
before his term officially ends on
january 20th
bad enough that hipster rasputin over
there in silicon valley thinks
that he has the right to tell the
president what he can say
and what he cannot say what he can do
and what he cannot do
now you've got a bank in new york a new
york bank
saying we we ought to be more powerful
than the duly elected president
we want him to step aside and we're
going to close his bank accounts
they're not just coming for trump
i i want to dispel this rumor
this this absolute canard that
if some other republican had gotten the
nomination in 2016
first of all that that republican would
have won i'm not sure of that but even
if that republican had would have won
had had one rather then the left would
have gone easy and the temperature would
be lower and everything would be fine
there were many many articles published
in 2015 and 2016.
with with variations on this headline
everyone's worried about trump but rubio
is much
scarier you're all worried about trump
but you should be much more afraid of
ted cruz
mitt romney who's a joke he's a liberal
milk toast
supine submissive
squish for the liberal establishment i
don't know how many more adjectives i
could possibly use
to describe how liberal
by republican standards mitt romney is
in in 2012 the president-elect
joe biden said he wanted to put black
people back in chains
in 2012 they said mitt romney was
a homophobic assailant who would clip
the hair of some gay guy in school or
something remember that story
he is so vicious he's such a psycho that
he
put his dog on the roof of the family
car in a cage when he went on vacation
remember that remember that story line
that psycho mitt romney that maniac who
wanted to take his dog on vacation
who does i don't i would never take a
dog on vacation it's a nice enough guy i
don't even like mitt romney but he's a
nice enough guy that he brings his dog
on vacation
and that is evidence that he's a psycho
they would have done this to any
republican
maybe trump is a little funnier about it
maybe he's a little more of a jerk
about it so he fires them up a little
bit more but in other ways
trump is a little more liberal in his
behavior and in his historical views
in his you know much of his career in
new york he was kind of a more liberal
guy
in some ways they liked trump more than
remember they said we we hate trump but
you can't impeach trump because
pence is worse pence is going to
electrocute gays remember that
storyline was that based on nothing but
that was the way oh you got to watch out
for pence
now because they just turn on any
republicans in office
is got to be the incarnation of evil
you have to say anyone who even possibly
could oppose trump
is so much better which is why they have
a strange new respect for mitt romney
or bill crystal who they used to call a
war criminal or the cheney family used
to call them war criminals
or pence used to say he was a maniac
electrocuting homosexuals
it's so naive so naive to think that
it's just about trump
it's not about trump they're not after
trump they're after you it's not just
some bank in new york
here's uh here's forbes forbes
magazine says a truth reckoning why
we're holding those who lied for trump
accountable
this is written by randall lane he's the
sort of adult man
who who wears a very silly looking
fedora
so it tells you a lot about him chief
content officer and
editor of forbes
he's talking about the insurrection and
the lies and the blah blah blah kind of
boilerplate democrat talking points but
then he comes to his point
he says that if any
company hires president trump's ex-press
secretaries
ex-spokesman people like kaylee
mcintyny people like sarah sanders
people like kellyanne conway who would
speak for the president on television
if any firms hire them forbes will
destroy those companies
forbes will take special measures
to try to destroy those companies
because they want these people who
worked for trump
to be unemployable talk about
the patriarchy he's specifically talking
about all these women he says look
ex-press secretaries of the at the white
house they go out and they make a lot of
money guys like ari fleischer or jay
carney and okay that's
fine but we don't want the trump ones to
make money
we want their lives to be ruined we want
them to be completely ostracized from
society
they're not just talking about kaylee
first of all i think ten thousand swords
should leave from their scabbards to
avenge even an insulting glance
at kaylee mcinnani alright but it's not
just about kayleigh it's not just about
sarah
it's not just about kellyanne it's about
you
the the forbes content chief content
officer
is coming after you what he's what he's
really saying
the subtext of this column is we don't
want any of you people who supported
trump any of you 75 million
nazis irredeemable deplorables
we don't want any of you to have a job
ever again we don't want you to be able
to vote ever again
we don't want you to be able to speak
ever again on social media
we don't want you to have anything to do
with society i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the michael knowles show to
check out the full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you